progress is a nonprofit organization
within Carnegie Mellon University and it
started because it's based on our
faculty director who is dr. Linda
Babcock who wrote lemon don't ask and
ask for it we understand that there's a
propensity for women to hold back and
how that plays a role in the lead in
leadership gap so rather than just
reporting this research by creating
tools to counteract how growth or
socialized to not speak up and their own
behalf is why progress really exists
breathing speak up is our annual program
if we're all community girls come
together to learn one thing and that is
how to negotiate we put it in very
interactive ways so there's been
activity such as bargain hunters and
wish there you know trading items within
their bad so it's really I'm saying what
is your goal identifying you know when
to walk away and to really start being
creative or the roleplay activity which
is green with envy we're girls get into
these roles they're presented this
personality and they have to discuss how
can we come to a solution with set rules
there's also a video that they've
watched that we've created our progress
called double take one short story is
about a rumor and how to address that
rumor when you found out who is the
person you know spreading this rumor
online and it's you know asking the
right questions finding out why did you
do this and how can we solve it and
really looking at who can you bring into
the session to help you whether it's a
teacher a parent guardian or peer you
can see how this starts aligning to if
you were an adult and you're a position
negotiating over your salary or a
position within a company or on a
working team all of the volunteers there
were 19 of us in total were trained to
run the group session so I think this is
a good experience not only for the kids
who participated today where they got to
learn about how to negotiate or speak up
for themselves but also for our
undergrads and graduate students to
actually learn not only how to negotiate
for themselves through ayanna's seminar
when she came here but also to teach
other people one of
see that women and young girls of all
ages can be excited about these kinds of
things when I asked what they had
learned one young girl said when you've
learned not to be quiet which is
wonderful hopefully we can I have speak
up everywhere
[Music]